do you remember how President Trump
could never pass tax reform in his first
year much like the prediction that he
would never deregulate never nominate an
original as justice to the Supreme Court
never pull out of the Paris climate
Accord never renegotiate trade deals
with our partners overseas never
annihilate Isis within eleven months
never helped to defund Planned
Parenthood never fight abortion at home
and overseas never defeat Hillary
Clinton never even win the Republican
nomination in 2016 do you remember that
turns out that that was all fake news we
will analyze the Senate tax bill and
what it means for the future of the
country in the administration then Laura
Baron Lopez from the Washington Examiner
and Amanda Prestage jacquimo from The
Daily wire joined the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss Trump's late
endorsement of Roy Moore his rien d'Or
sment the FBI indictment of Mike Flynn
and the Person of the Year
I know who it should be I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]
what a weekend I'm celebrating with a
little Kofi faking a little candy cough
if it came it was I wish we had a show
on Friday that we could have done it but
it was nice
we've had a few days to mull over all I
guess it happened on Saturday anyway
we've had a few days to mull over this
excellent tax reform and you know I am
old enough to remember when tax reform
was a total impossibility a pipe dream
by Trump cultists who couldn't wake up
and smell the coffee or the coffe fa and
realize the president Trump is
incompetent leftist or an incompetent
leftist let's roll the predictions of
the consensus class the tax bill is not
going to get passed I know you're
talking about it before 0% chance of
this being passed like zero there's
ninety nine percent for tax reform
because they're gonna need a win well
it's dead but maybe not dead and buried
fear the tax reform is dead will there
be tax cuts and if the companies really
were trying to advocate for tax cuts
cuts would've been better to stay at the
president's side maybe that's a sign
Stephen Moore that tax cuts might not
happen - mm-hmm
form is dead real true tax reform it's
just tax cuts and can this can this
isolated president get that agenda
through if they can't pass this tax
reform and so far we've seen President
Trump giving pep talks and photo ops but
we haven't seen anything come out of it
yeah turns out none of that was true
none of that always true it wasn't true
because the consensus view is almost
always wrong that this is a hard thing
to realize weaving the consensus view is
right everyone thinks that all the smart
people think is therefore must be right
but that isn't true forget about Galileo
and Copernicus consider just the regular
sports economic political predictions we
see every night on television consider
the scientific consensus on
overpopulation 30 years ago and on food
shortages that never happened on global
cooling then when that didn't happen
global warming and then when those
didn't predictions didn't work out on
climate change consider the electoral
consensus smart money's on GEB to win
the primary but Hillary's she'll
certainly win the general the fact that
the consensus is wrong is how people
make money in the stock market you're
making the stock Marie you're making a
bet that the consensus is baked into the
price and that it's incorrect that you
know better we're seeing this play out
and again with Trump the next time
somebody condescends and patronizes
calls you crazy for thinking that
perhaps Donald Trump has a couple of
brain cells to rub together it may be
that he's perhaps an effective leader
remind them of this fact now let's get
on to the tax bill itself first from my
wardrobe today I have to thank oh and
Brennan and Justin Foulke who are the
guys they're the guys doing the dennis
prager and adam carolla movie no safe
spaces which is a lot of fun it's gonna
be great when it comes out they gave me
this shirt it says keep calm and cut
taxes keep calm and cut taxes and both
sides of that are important if you know
it's playing on the old British slogan
keep calm and carry on you know both
sides are important the left is losing
its collective mind over tax reform
Larry Summers is claiming I kid you not
that 10,000 people will die because of
reforming taxes Talking Heads have
compared allowing people to keep more of
their own money to rape comedian Patton
Oswald wrote quote is there any going
back after this tax bill scam to America
does it matter now if Trump is impeached
there's no America now not the one we
knew I'm sorry I'm feeling real despair
this morning I'm sure he is leftist
blogger bill Palmer shrieks quote
millions of Americans died tonight
they debt now you might not have seen
that on the news because it didn't
happen you know but they died quote so
did the careers of every one of those
psychotic drooling animals in the
Republican Party who voted for it this
was mass murder
keep calm Keep Calm it's okay baby baby
it's okay letting people keep more if
their own money it's not mass murder
it's going to be fine actually
ironically my taxes are going to
increase which is unfortunate especially
if this grad student tax goes through
I'm gonna get hit it's a double whammy
on the state and local and the grad
student tax because my fiance is getting
a PhD but it is far better for the
country and for economic growth actually
Democrats always accused Republicans of
being greedy and selfish on taxes but
guess what if mine increase that that's
because I do decently well in a city and
state with absurd taxation for a long
time California and LA have gotten a
free pass on federal income taxes while
the rest of the country subsidizes their
insane tax rates the Republican tax
reform really
those incentives to be both fairer more
federalists to be more pro-growth so I
might pay a bit more but I'll live and
on the whole this law is great for
liberty and for the economy
the only people this law is terrible for
our Democrat politicians who are doing
their best to obstruct a pro-growth Pro
Liberty agenda because they know it's
gonna kill their election chances in
2018 and 2020 Lindsey Graham laid it out
pretty frankly he said Republicans have
to do this if Republicans cannot come
together and unite on reforming the tax
code lowering rates and reforming the
code they might as well fold up as a
party which doesn't make some sense if
you can't convince a bunch of
Republicans to cut taxes but what our
there isn't a Republican Party anymore
so what does the bill actually do the
bill lowers and simplifies income tax
rates doubles the standard deduction
doubles the shot to child tax credit it
preserves the adoption tax credit which
is good it's a good bit of pro-life
wiggling in the the federal government
median income family of four sees a
reduction of $2,200 per year so
Democrats are gonna shriek that it's
only the rich who benefit from this
first of all half the country doesn't
pay any taxes so the rich probably
should benefit from this but the median
medium income earner and with a family
of four gets over $2,000 per year in tax
deduction which is a great thing more
importantly it lowers the corporate tax
rate to 20% this does matter people are
gonna try to convince you that it
doesn't matter because some gigantic
companies keep a lot of cash overseas
and they pay very little in taxes but a
lot of businesses in this country do pay
taxes especially in sectors like energy
finance retail Home Depot pays a very
high effective tax rate cable companies
waste management fast food there are a
lot of areas of American industry that
do pay taxes this is going to bolster
them it also repeals the Obamacare
mandate this is one of the best parts
it's great maybe we can get some money
up from corporations overseas maybe we
can stimulate job growth but this this
bill repeals the Obamacare mandate the
federal penalty that requires Americans
for the first time ever to purchase a
good from a private company totally
antithetical to American liberty now
that it's past the difficult hurdle
which is the Senate it seems likely to
end up in the final bill this is
great news now for the sort of bad news
the Senate tax plan is predicted to
increase the u.s. deficit by one
trillion dollars to one point four
trillion dollars over the next decade I
say this sort of bad news because this
is from the CBO and the Joint Committee
on taxation these sorts of predictions
are usually off they're usually
hyperbolic the growth prediction at the
root here is just 0.8% economic growth
we have plenty of reason to suspect that
this is way too low
third quarter US economic growth is
already beating expectations so Trump's
first year these numbers came out just a
little while ago already exceeded
expectations for the first time in a
decade actual economic growth has
exceeded maximum potential economic
growth so economists are predicting
stronger wage and price increases
because the economy is operating beyond
its potential this is great news for the
Federal Reserve which is worried for
years about sluggish inflation still
even granting all of that even granting
that probably these numbers are off the
tax cuts might exacerbate the deficit
that's not a good thing so what can we
do about that president Trump has
already signaled what he intends to do I
know you don't want this welfare reform
does anybody want welfare and
infrastructure but welfare reform I see
it and I've talked to people I know
people they work three jobs and they
live next to somebody who doesn't work
at all and the person who's not working
at all and has no intention of working
at all is making more money and doing
better than the person that's working
his and her ass off and it's not going
to happen not gonna happen
so we're gonna go into welfare reform
unless Billy doesn't want it Billy on my
okay and saying they speak for you he
said yes not not exactly Reagan asked
addiction but hey that's okay we'll take
what we can get Rubio and Ryan among
others are also saying the same thing
but what does this mean by welfare
reform Trump he isn't just talking about
Obama care for Obama phones or whatever
you know they very often they'll they
would say Trump isn't gonna talk deal
with entitlements but what he's doing
he's so brilliant he's tying entitlement
reform Medicare Medicaid Social Security
which are the main drivers of our
national debt and deficits he's tying
that to welfare reform so the image of
the welfare queen and the the Obama
thumb he's painting a picture of the
cause of our economic woes and the cause
of our long-term problems that we can
digest and get behind we can picture the
problem of welfare and and it's accurate
by the way it's not alight these
problems are welfare they're albeit
that's welfare that the government has
forced us to pay into for years but it
is a welfare system so instead of
typically think of Medicare Medicaid
Social Security we can't envision this
doesn't mean anything all it really all
that really sounds like does is that
rich people want to take away things
that we've paid into for a long time
he's pointing out that this is
essentially a welfare regime and we need
to reform that for for our long-term
prosperity now it has long been common
knowledge consensus knowledge you might
say that Trump would never touch
entitlements he said so himself
but Donald Trump says a lot of things
and and what does he mean by that well
let's let's see what everyone's telling
us probably said he will not touch those
well you have to be very careful about
words like not touching does it mean I
won't cut them I won't cut them for
current retirees nobody would suggest
cutting Social Security benefits for cut
it for current retirees but I think
doing what President Reagan did in 1983
gradually reducing the future benefits
read out over a number of years and
after a long delay but gradually
reducing it by changing the age of
retirement
now Feldstein makes a great point here
everyone's saying he won't touch
entitlements he won't touch entitlements
but what do you mean by touch that that
is the wiggle room that's the wiggle
room that he's given himself
Gerald FCB observed in The Wall Street
Journal today quote it's clear that mr.
Trump's Barb's directed at senior
members of his own party Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell John McCain Jeff Flake
bob corker Paul Ryan they don't get in
the way of the GOP uniting for something
really important the idea that
Republicans can repeat that feat in 2018
on health and infrastructure doesn't
seem so far-fetched if the past is any
indication I am not so sure that he'll
never touch entitlements I'm not sure of
anything he seems to have managed to
repeal the major pillar of Obamacare
while simultaneously reforming our tax
code the only thing I'm willing to
conclude for sure about this
administration is we should never say
never when it comes to Trump with that
let's bring on our panel we have a man
to press to Giacomo from The Daily wire
and Laura Baron Lopez from the
Washington Examiner Laura thank you for
coming on your first time on the panel
of deplorable --zz what what is the
final bill going to look like well as
you alluded to they have to go to
conference and so that's something that
they're hoping to wrap up by the end of
the year and it looks like they are
going to be able to do that you know in
the House and Senate bill there were
some compromises worked out in order to
get people like Susan Collins and others
on Collins wanted to see the compromise
that was in the House bill when it came
to salt the state and local tax
deductions included in the Senate so
you're going to be seeing them work
things out like that when it goes to
conference but honestly I don't really
see any
stopping it at this point it's
unbelievable because if you'd asked me I
don't by the way I don't mean to harp on
the consensus view and say they're all
idiots and I knew better I didn't know I
didn't make predictions that were really
different than all of this
I just with held my immediate judgment
because this was a guarantee just a
month or two ago that we could never get
tax reform even more recently than that
and then it happens now to get even more
excited to really gear the cafe meter up
to 11 Amanda is there any shot that we
get entitlement reform I mean we might
like you said there I'm not gonna put
anything past Trump I know that he said
he would not touch these things during
the campaign but but who knows I mean
his main platform was immigration and we
haven't seen too much going on there I
mean we've seen a crackdown with ice and
ain't no Border Patrol and stuff like
that but we haven't seen you know him
exactly sticking to the script I mean if
you look at Ann Coulter's Twitter feed
right now you know she'll tell you that
the border wall there's zero
construction but we're going you know
but we have tax reforms so I'm not sure
I'm not sure he might touch it it's
conservatives would be obviously on
board for that I don't think the
populist base is totally on you know 100
percent behind though that's not their
main concern but I wouldn't put it past
him to touch it Ann Coulter's Twitter
feed is the evidence of this you're
exactly right his Trump zig zags he zigs
egg so you can't really pin him down he
puts out this is the Kofi by the way he
puts out so much coffe FA all the time
that by the time you catch up to the one
crazy thing he's doing over here he's on
to something else
and this isn't just the personal stuff
and the language or whatever it does
throw a salty language and even in the
pitch for entitlement reform in Missouri
that we just watched he throws in bad
words and things but by the time he's
over here then he's he's moving on to
the border wall or he's moving on to
entitlement reform it's it's hard to
keep up with that and it's really hard
to make predictions predictions only
work when you can model normal times and
normal experiences and that's why maybe
the polls were all right during the age
of Romney but we're not we are not in
normal times now before we get on we
have so much more to talk about the real
person of the year and the first little
bad news we'll talk
about with mr. Mike Flynn and what that
means for the administration but first
you can probably tell you looking in my
eyes you can see how excited I am
I'm just sucking on this candy cane to
keep me awake for the sugar I have not
slept in day as I've been so excited
about tax reform but when you are ready
to sleep it's very important I'm gonna
crash after this I'm probably gonna get
my customary fourteen hours of sleep
sleep is very important you spend a
third of your life doing it I spent
about two-thirds of my life doing it and
there are a ton of online mattress
retailers popping up these days I have
moved around a bunch in my 20s from
college to New York to LA I've always
bought a new mattress I don't move it
with me it's expensive mattress shopping
is terrible I hate it more than even
regular shopping so as a millennial I
don't want to spend a ton of money I
want to get the best deal possible for
for the quality and I never want to
leave my chair I want to stay glued to
it so all of these online mattress
solutions they'll give you a
one-size-fits-all answer for a better
sleep but guess what one size does not
fit all the consensus view is always
wrong as we've been talking about so you
got to get a little more particular
helix sleep offers something that
doesn't exist anywhere else which is a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that
won't set you back at gazillion dollars
now I know what you're thinking the
economy is about to get way way better
and so I can spend my money anywhere
save it don't worry there are a lot of
other great things to spend your money
on go to helix sleep comm slash Knowles
kayano wles
take their two to three minutes sleep
quiz I don't do anything that takes more
than four minutes this is two to three
minutes do it they will build a custom
mattress that will be the best thing
you've ever slept on for couples for
those of you who have found some partner
to just trudge through life with and
enjoy this wonderful Trumpy journey this
scoff FA journey they will personalize
each side of the mattress that's pretty
good everyone from GQ to Cosmo to the
New York Times we're talking about helix
once you try it out you will know why
now your custom mattress will arrive
directly to you within a week that's
pretty good what do you have to pay very
little shipping is completely free you
can try it for 100 nights if you don't
love it they'll pick it up and refund
you in full so go to helix sleep calm
slash and Knowles right now while you're
there check out the mattress
Tector check out the foundation they got
a lot of good stuff but at least look at
the mattress seriously because it
actually does matter you should spend
money on mattresses you should spend
money on the things that you're gonna
spend a lot of time on right now if you
go to helix sleep comm slash Knowles
Kano wles like Beyonce
you will save $50 you'll get $50 toward
your custom mattress helix sleep comm
slash Knowles $50 off your order
helix sleep comm slash Knowles all right
even the thought of sleeping on one of
those lovely helix beds has gotten me
kind of tired but don't forget our third
episode of the conversation is coming up
on Tuesday December 12th at 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific featuring the one
and the only the bus man himself the
Slayer of lefty snowflakes ben shapiro
subscribe today to be a part of the
conversation you can ask Ben live
questions he will answer every one that
they have time for it you get it coming
in basically in order so sign up right
now and you can talk to Ben I know have
my Twitter feed is just people trying to
talk to Ben so you can subscribe today
and you'll be able to do it it will
stream live on the daily wire Facebook
page and the daily wire YouTube channel
you can all watch it for free but only
subscribers can ask the questions log in
to our website daily wire.com head over
the conversation page to watch the live
stream then you can just type right into
the daily wired chat box Ben will answer
all of your questions all of the
life-changing questions in the order
they come in subscribe to get your
questions in by Tuesday December 12th 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific now the
trouble is this not only do you get that
I would that would be enough of a sale I
think but if you subscribe right now
that the trouble is this if you're not
subscribed you can't continue to watch
the show thank you everyone who does
subscribe you keep the lights on in Co
FFA and mic up if you haven't go there
right now you get me get the
conversation thing at the end of clayvin
show you get banned rap baba baba i
don't know if you've noticed the weather
around you since we've gotten tax reform
but i am up to my ears in leftist tears
they are pouring out everywhere i hope
you haven't logged on in facebook or
twitter because they are seeping out
there you'll fry your whole computer get
the only vessel that will allow you to
hold
of those tasty salty left his tears hot
or cold the leftist here's tumblr go to
the daily wire.com right now for an
annual membership it's ten bucks a month
a hundred dollars for an annual
membership if you get the ladder you get
the leftist here's tumblr daily
wired.com after all of that great news
we'll be right back
you know the holiday season is upon us
you know Christmas shopping has landed
because that was just like 10 minutes of
telling you all the great stuff that you
have to get right now but now we got to
bring it down a little bit I know we
were having such a great buffet day I
got the mistletoe sitting right behind
me if anybody gets any ideas who isn't
named Marshall president Trump has rien
dorste endorsed again beleaguered
Alabama Senate candidate Roy Moore he
said quote Democrats refusal to give
even one vote for massive tax cuts is
why we need a Republican Roy Moore to
win in Alabama we need his vote on
stopping crime illegal immigration
border wall military pro life VA judges
Second Amendment and more no to Jones a
pelosi schumer puppet he went on 280
characters were not enough quote putting
pelosi schumer liberal puppet jones into
office in alabama would hurt our great
republican agenda of low on taxes tough
on crime strong on military and borders
and so much more look at your 401 k's
since the election could point hiya
stock market ever jobs are roaring back
where's the lie I don't know Amanda
should Trump have rien dorste more like
this was this the right call normal
presidents would probably not do this
probably not but President Trump is not
a normal president so for him coming out
I mean I guess I was a little surprised
even though I shouldn't have been and as
you as you notice he didn't say anything
about the accusations whose just like it
doesn't matter if we need to push this
agenda forward and I think that kind of
I mean this is a really gross thing all
around but if you look at what's
happened on the Left I mean we had al
franken he's still you know in office
they're gonna have a nice investigation
so that kind of watered down these
allegations as well on your side snip
down even though Pelosi is actually
exactly yeah so this this me two
movements kind of been watered down a
little bit the people of Alabama I think
was 71 percent don't even believe the
accusations because there's such a
distrust with media for good reason
that's not to say these accusations are
not true I'm just saying that's kind of
the consensus
in Alabama that's always right so I
don't think a particularly hurts Trump
but it is a bold move for him to come
out and say this I think a any other
Republican president would not touch it
at the very least but that is not
president Trump that is now Trump now
Laura you're a real journalist so you
deal in numbers an ID link offa so I'd
like to know how close is more can he
win did he need president Trump's Rhee
endorsement to win I don't think he
needed Trump's endorsement he he is
ticking back up in the polls after doug
jones we saw him take the lead a little
bit when this was first in the new cycle
and and dominating the new cycle but as
you said you know with the Franken and
the Conyers allegations that kind of was
a little bit of a gift tomorrow
um I would like to say though that I
think there's a pretty big distinction
between someone who has been accused of
molesting children and Franken who has
been accused of sexual harassment and
Conyers who's been accused of sexual
harassment there's another difference
too by the way which is that all of the
Roy Moore accusations and I'm not saying
they're not credible they seem perfectly
credible but all of those happened 40
years ago and those photos of Al Franken
are from within the last ten years of
him getting hands happy mean forty years
ago makes them any less relevant or
makes them any less important I mean as
we know women don't come forward when
these things happen I mean these women
were children there was fourteen year
old you know thirteen year old it was
their 13 I thought it was 14 16 14 16
but the point still stands that they
were underage and well this is my
question though do you not think that it
obviously those allegations whether
whether they're credible or not just
that they're made should cause some
reflection but does it not say something
that about Roy Moore's character that he
hasn't had any accusations within 40
years if he were some kind of creepy sex
guy then what we even if we conclude
that we could say he seems to have
reformed himself
for four decades that I think that says
something about his character today
I would say that you can't really say
that someone has reformed himself when
they aren't even admitting any
wrongdoing and I think that all the
accusations are credible and there have
been multiple women that have come out
over the course of his career and maybe
you could say that no one came forward
because at some point he got married and
he has been married to Kayla since then
apparently faithfully apparently but
again that doesn't mean that he has
reformed when he's there in the church
saying that you know he didn't do this
and he is saying that he knows the right
way and his way is God's Way when he
can't even admit any wrongdoing I'm
sorry but I really don't think that
there's any reform there I mean and then
another difference is that Franken has
admitted wrongdoing
now Conyers of course is also denying
all the allegations but you aren't
seeing Democratic leaders do what Trump
did and Democratic leaders are saying
you need to step down and you shouldn't
step down now yeah maybe it took them a
week to say that it took them 20 years
after Bill Clinton to say that it took
them up a lot more than a week starting
directing with that Bill Clinton also
was you know went through an entire
trial I mean the left internal Naledi
went through a trial because Republicans
made it yes at the time but you are also
seeing left wing or left wing groups as
well as senators come forward and
wanting to go back to that it's
convenient
Gillibrand when Gillibrand yes there is
probably some political motivation
behind her doing that but she did come
forward and say that Clinton should have
resigned if we go back to it now it is
certainly convenient now yes I mean I
wouldn't say it's necessarily convenient
for certain outside groups that weren't
around then and they're coming forward
saying that yes the left should reckon
with what Bill Clinton did but again if
we are going to talk about everything
which I think that we should then we
also should talk about the fact that
Trump himself was accused by 16 women so
this is something that is a really big
topic in DC right now it's something
that isn't going to go away and I think
you're going to see a lot more name
people being named in Congress on both
sides of the aisle and it's something
that Congress needs to handle and they
should probably handle it it's
expeditiously as they possibly can you
know I will say I did notice those
left-wing groups
didn't come forward in October in
November of 2016 I noticed they waited a
few months until the Clintons were no
longer viable but it's true they're
dealing with it now and you make this
great point about the reckoning with Roy
Moore which is I think it's certainly
evidence that if those allegations are
true for decades of good behavior and of
not doing creepy weird sex stuff is
evidence of reform but he's the guy out
there on this pedestal saying that I'm
the candidate of Christian virtues and
he hasn't acknowledged that he's
accusations are true he hasn't
apologized he hasn't done a lot of
things that one would hope a Christian
would do if the accusations are credible
but of course there are a ton of
political calculations that go into all
of this that is the that is the bit that
makes Roy Moore look a little slick and
a little oily even if he's been a good
guy for 40 years that he can't admit it
is a little tough to reckon with for
sure and even beside that it's not all
cough FA News today Bob Muller has
indicted former Trump advisor Mike Flynn
for lying to the FBI
now Andy McCarthy thinks this is
evidence that Muller doesn't have
anything on Trump he thinks that if
Muller had something on Trump he would
have gotten Mike Flynn to plead guilty
to a crime related to rush a conspiracy
and that way it's the evidence of the
crime and then that way they can get the
big dog who ordered him but he didn't do
that he just pled guilty to a procedural
crime Marc Levin thinks the same thing
he says that there's no there's nothing
to this Russia conspiracy issue and
collusion
Laura does Muller have anything on Trump
well I think that none of us can really
say that we know its molar has anything
on Trump but I will say that I don't
necessarily agree with that assessment
that you just mentioned and I think that
the fact that Flynn Flynn only pled
guilty to one charge is the sign that
Moe that he's cooperating with the
investigation and that the reason that
there's some dealings going on and so
the reason he was only charged with one
count was because Muller is working with
him to get a bigger fish that's
certainly the consensus view that's
certainly the consensus
why that chore given the fact that we
have seen molar be very calculating if
you aren't going to cooperate with him
then maybe he will charge you with more
counts if he has the evidence if someone
is going to cooperate and he thinks that
there is someone bigger who committed a
far more treasonous crime or some other
thing that he wants thread that he wants
to pursue and someone is cooperating
with him then he's going to work out a
plea deal with that but the mainstream
media they had to walk out back all of
their reporting on this they said that
he was it seems that Flynn was ordered
by Jared Kushner to conspire with
Russian to call Russia what we then
learned is he called members of the
United Nations including Russia and said
don't vote to destroy Israel don't vote
to condemn Israel in this particular
resolution I just wonder if it is this
plea deal which seems to be the
consensus view then why didn't Flynn get
him to plead guilty to a crime to any
crime that would help him further the
case that the Trump campaign colluded
with Russia why would he just get him on
this little procedural and I don't I
don't mean as a lying to the FBI is not
a big deal
but it was a procedural crime it was a
crime that was caused by the
investigation itself Amanda thank you
because sorry go ahead yeah no that's
that's kind of the point here that
McCarthy at National Review was making
is that that's not how it works and he
was a former prosecutor that's not how
this would work he would get him on
something bigger and if he had it you
know he went just go after committee you
know lying to the FBI so that's kind of
the point here is that this is all he
has and it looks like I mean as of now
we have no evidence of collusion which
is not even a crime this is the only
thing we have is that he lied to the FBI
I mean what Flynn did is he reached out
to Russian you know Russians what after
President Trump was elected so when he
was the president-elect and he was part
of the incoming administration that's
nothing again we just we have more
nothing coming up there's no collusion
there's no nothing this more and more as
this progresses looks like a witch hunt
I hate to use that term but that's
exactly what it looks like unless we
have something soon I mean I don't
see anything if someone can tell me one
piece of Russian collusion which again
it's not a crime I'd love to hear it but
we have nothing thus far the only thing
we have is is Flynn lying to the FBI
which is not small potatoes not saying
that but where is the crime like I don't
see anything you know it is a witch hunt
certainly but sometimes there are
witches Laura do you have any any
thoughts on who might fall if if Muller
does have something do you have any
thoughts on where this could lead or do
you agree with Amanda that basically
where we're seeing the last throes of a
witch hunt I don't think we're seeing
the last years of a witch hunt I think
that this could go all the way to the
present not necessarily on a collusion
which again is not illegal to be
discussing things with foreign state
when you're an incoming administration
of course when you're an incoming
administration yes but we saw his tweet
this weekend which of course you have to
take every tweet that comes from the
president with the grain of salt because
it could not be true that's the state
that we're living in right now but
Trump's tweet pretty much it says that
he knew that Flynn committed a crime
when he fired Comey
and if that timeline plays out and if
that timeline is accurate and Trump
didn't know that Flynn had lied to the
FBI when he fired Comey and that is
pretty strong evidence of an attempt to
obstruct justice and so that is where
Muller will be able to get him if that
is something that he is looking at and
and now I would say that the president
has opened himself up to more scrutiny
of course the lawyer did say hey I
penned that tweet that being said we've
never had heard the lawyers say that
before and so again either way this is
something that Moeller has to be looking
at more now given that Trump threw this
out there certainly and you can always
indict a ham sandwich so there like it
is very different I don't mean that
glibly it is difficult for these
investigations to conclude without
getting somebody for something but the
question is are we are we going to
continue to hear in insinuations of so
called Russia collusion or are we are
they basically going to bring this down
to some procedural crime and will
get scooter libby part 2 or something i
don't know there is the truth the tweets
could get him in trouble that's that is
the the cost of all the great
communication that you get out of
twitter bypassing the mainstream media
going direct to the american people the
cost of that is you open yourself up to
a lot of on-the-record statements and
your your claim in this sac checked
yeah and just one thing i know ben
shapiro talked about this earlier even
that even let's say because of that
tweet let's say trump pen that was from
trump even that would possibly not be
obstruction of justice Ben Spiros that
said who's looking at all the statutes
and that wouldn't be obstruction of
justice because the investigation is
still going on you can fire combing for
whatever reason he wants and we sell
this special councilor nothing nothing
happened there so it's still proceeding
so even that worst-case scenario would
not technically not be obstruction of
justice I haven't personally looked at
those statutes I'm just taking this from
Ben Shapiro who is a lawyer and said he
looked at them so it's not exactly the
most Pro Trump guy in the world he's not
Magga had every day so I do take it
pretty significantly if he's pointing
that out well this does get to the most
important question in the news today
forget Flynn forget taxes in the economy
and everything Time magazine has its
shortlist Person of the Year
now that list includes the dreamers
quote-unquote you know the dreamers the
dreamers you know the bet that's the
euphemism of the year a little rocket
man Kim jong-un anti-american dum-dum
Colin Kaepernick
Kaepernick the hashtag me too movement
Bob Muller and others Amanda Laura who
is the person of the year regardless of
whether or not they are on Times list
Laura we'll start with you who should be
the person of the year and who his time
gonna name those I assume those are very
different questions they are I think
that time may try to go with something
broader so I think that given everything
that's being discussed across the
country right now I could see them going
with me too yeah movement that's you
know the sexual harassment assault
reckoning the
the USS havening is is not going to go
away and it really did become a big
force this year so I would maybe say
that that's where they're gonna go and
it has of all the slacktivism pains and
we get a new one every single day it
does appear that hashtag me too has
overtaken hashtag taken knee for the
virtue signaling so that that is the one
we're talking about that might get it
Amanda who do you think yeah I think I
think they're gonna choose the me to
campaign but I mean if we didn't know
Time magazine was left-wing before I
mean these these are the I mean the
dreamers Robert Mueller I mean anyone
who Donald Trump doesn't like it's like
on this list but I I think they're gonna
go with the me to campaign which is not
a person which is kind of weird
and who should it be I don't know
Toronto just say true that there's no
question I mean this is what happens
when you get a showman and a showrunner
and a reality TV megastar to be your
president is at least for the first year
he's the guy right he is the guy if you
when was the last time you had a meal
where as desperately as you tried for
Trump not to come up someone had to
bring up whatever tweet he sent out it's
just I don't know is like the 90s was
the last time I talked I didn't talk
about that guy outrage yeah I think
that's probably true although if they do
go with the dreamers you could always
have the compliment to that would be the
night mirrors of all that voters who
made Donald Trump the president I'm sure
they would they would give it to them to
the nightmare for 2017 but pretty cool
feffy on our end thank you both for
being here Laura Baron Lopez from the
Washington Examiner great to have you
will have to have you back and a man to
press to Giacomo from The Daily wire
excellent as always to have you that's
our show I was yapping so much during a
show I only had a little bit of my candy
cane to celebrate the beginning of
Advent we will be back as long as this
mistletoe doesn't get me arrested for
you know the hashtag me too thing and if
that doesn't happen if if the Hollywood
crumbling doesn't affect my studio too
we will be back here tomorrow
I am I gonna lose the Michael Noel's
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Nolt show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017